hey warner brothers you already pulled
this crap with godzilla vs kong do you
think you can release more than two
seconds of footage from mortal kombat
i don't think so
[Music]
it's tomorrow the trailers tomorrow a
lot of people said it would be super
bowl
it wasn't but it's tomorrow you guys are
right it's in february
what's going on reject nation greg and
john here today
so uh last night and this morning
apparently they were unloading some
mortal kombat
movie posters just to pump us up even
more
for the trailer that's coming out got a
shout out this guy
on my twitter name butcherbilly here's
some messages as you can see i haven't
opened them yet because i was like well
gotta react to them but based off his
last message i was like this must be the
mortal kombat posters he was so
desperately
wanted me to take a look at so with that
in mind we're gonna watch
chris's 3c films video on it breaking it
down
he put this up a few hours ago i wonder
if all them are included in here let's
see what's in store
the only one i've seen is uh subzero
just to be perfectly transparent anywho
let's go into this
this is chris parker attempting to find
news to make a video on for the
following day
until he sees a mortal combat character
poster
only problem is they'll release them one
by one
beginning at 2 a.m his time oh no buddy
to talk movies for a living at the
expense of his dignity for you
yeah stay awake hour by hour
hoping to see the amazing costume
designs for the mortal kombat movie
thinking it will bring him happiness if
people watch him
intro game strong to realize
nothing will ever bring him true
happiness i'm morgan freeman
and as someone on mortal kombat would
say please
finish me hey my name is chris that
might be
my favorite opening only because i
strongly relate
that was great dude i'm proud of you
that was a damn good one
plus intro we've gotten some character
posters that have just landed online oh
look
what a nice watch you gotta woke up this
morning and get to see all of them right
now in their full glory
ain't she lucky for the upcoming mortal
kombat movie not only did they go ahead
and appreciate the hustle we'll be
getting
the full trailer come this thursday
that ain't even the best part they have
confirmed that it will be
a red red band
basically
and they started off with the banger
right now okay currently it's only 12
a.m
here and it is the character poster for
sub zero
sick poster sick poster glimpses of
sub-zero suit we've seen the back of it
we've seen little hints of it but right
here
in this motion poster in all its glory
my god that
[Music]
out of a live action mortal kombat movie
i think this one and the scorpion design
is what they really had to nail down and
so far me looking at the sub-zero design
they've got it down to it oh yeah i know
mortal kombat is on the lower budget
side but i'm hoping that they did spend
a lot of the budget on the special
effects
spend it all on this poster
on all their amazing powers we've been
promised fatalities that are going to be
faithful to the video games where
they're going to directly rip them out
of there and put them into the movie
i mean we've already seen so i'm so
excited to see what sub-zero
yes there it is there it is even weapons
that they make in the video games for
the actual movie
so so far this right there it is funny
now they did go ahead and kind of
downgrade by showing the next character
poster right here of
way cooler a lot of fans were kind of
disappointed with the look of kane
he's got to be grounded
but you know what this could just be a
simple setup i mean even zooming in a
little bit on his character poster here
it doesn't even look like it's clawed it
looks like this skin
can be ripped off and i would not be
surprised i love that this was the one
they toned down yeah
the one that's already toned down i know
there's the one they're like
we gotta make this even like more toned
down but but include the guy with the
full metal arc
that happens in the mortal kombat movie
where we start off with just this
regular red glowing eye
and towards the end he's going to get to
get ripped off
half of that face is just exposed full
metal
something more resembling his video game
counterpart other than that we do know
from
this is his movie his it's kato's
maybe in the beginning combat tournament
so while he might start off as a good
guy by the end of this working with
sonia blade
we know he's gonna start with his feud
most likely with sonia blade
next character poster here that they
revealed that
nice a.m instead of 2 a.m like they were
saying
i need my beard rest but this right here
is malina and she has been one fans have
been dying to see
i didn't know molina was in this movie
already looking at her design i think
they nailed it down
even with the purple lighting right
there that is pretty traditional with
her character
in the video games the one thing i was
hoping to see that we only get
kind of little glimpses that see that
mouth open up wow don't ask her
see that mouth open up it's because her
mouth is kind of the most iconic part
yeah
yeah giant sharp teeth putting it side
by side here with its video game
counterpart i mean you could tell
what we are expecting to see and i guess
they're going to be saving that effect
for the right
i hope so but here you know what's going
to be happening or else they would not
give her
those scopes it's great exaggerated look
on her cheek but again
these costumes man they really are just
a way higher step up than what we were
used to in the old movie that today
would feel like some cheap cosplay
convention terrific whoa whoa you have
to show
put it on screen then molina for mortal
kombat annihilation
now that that's that was special that's
faithful
next character poster here is someone
that is always getting confused as
raiden because of the big circumstances
people familiar with the mortal kombat
video games will know that this is kung
lao and again kung lao's alpha we got a
better look of it in other photos here
here is a side profile view of it
and i think it's looking pretty alright
usually in the video games he started
off as a peaceful fighter meaning
he would fight if he would have to but
he had made the desire to become the
best or even win the tournament
recently in the morning why am i here
why am i in the tournament
i'm not really invested in this he's
also known to be best friends almost
having a brother relationship with
the main character of the series which
is lou kang yeah i think they did this
costume just fine excited to see it by
the way this one dropped at 3 15 a.m
next character
time stamps coming up man this is the
feeling for your introduction
kombat
and be the newbie into the world of
mortal kombat so
because he's a brand new character has
no knowledge of what's going on mortal
kombat he's free to ask all these days
but he's got the dragon
for the audience but if people end up
liking him he could be a dlc in the
future mortal kombat games
that would that would be cool character
in the movie like this would be
enough to make it into the game that
would be neat i mean because this is the
one character i'm least looking forward
to and i'm kind of the most
skeptical and hesitant about being in
this at all you don't want a 90s regular
guy protagonist
if he is like really cool he ends up
being a dlc oh man that would be awesome
and as a plus synopsis mortal kombat is
correct this right here
is a birthmark that he was born with
that grants him access to be trained by
lord raiden
it said that all the fighters from earth
realm are born with this symbol
and that's how they know to join
together to fight for mortal kombat
because it's
their destiny aside from that cole young
is just an mma fighter with a heart of
gold
fighting for his daughter entering a
tournament not really knowing what he's
doing i'm so nervous about this
character
just trying to get back to my dog johnny
cage
i could have totally have seen johnny
cage being put in this role
and it working perfectly moving on to
the next costume here that i think again
they've nailed down and is nice what
did you know he was in this no although
i figured he would have to show up
somewhere
but that's the original actor magic in
use it is even the same color as it
would be in the video game hold on his
suit is also looking extremely menacing
is that him almost like there's
warped faces on his armor plate as if to
say these are his victims
of the video games it looks like he
could be the host of the mortal kombat
tournament
possibly even one of the biggest is that
the same actor i can't tell people
we know part of the plot synopsis also
said that people like sub-zero were
being sent
out for the future fighters in the
mortal kombat tournament and
killing them before they could even be
part of the tournament that's what's
going to be happening in the first 10
minutes of the movie where it's gonna be
scorpion versus sub zero before they
both got their powers at one point
sub-zero is even going to be going after
cole
young making sure he can't enter it
still though
go get cold right here next one hold on
yeah something to blake costume looks
great
she's got tank top cool all right i had
to pause it to see
like if that was the same actor because
this is shang tsung
yeah from the 1995 and it looks like
they're very similar
they look very similar it almost seems
like they want you to do a double tape
yeah but this is the guy who's playing
him right here
from the dark knight yes uh lao yeah
yeah
yeah okay i still think even when i do
this
even when i have his face here it still
looks like the original actor from the
1995 movie way more
than he does this new guy it's so funny
to me
at least we're both racist on this one i
was concerned about that but now i am
crap damn dang no i'm the only racist
one here
come on this looks more in my eye i'm
like that looks more like him
yeah it does it definitely especially
because the video game modeled their
look
yeah eventually after him that's just so
funny to me next one we have here is one
you can't really mess up and that's the
character poster for sonia blade
go to your little local thrift shop
go to a salvation army yeah you know
trying to figure out the mystery of
mortal kombat i'm still gonna be really
curious to see how the movie takes in
mythical characters with magical powers
finding regular people
who don't have any of these
[Music]
surprised they didn't end up making him
the main character since it seems
sometimes
he's the main character of the actual
video it was really the main character
in the first movie maybe cole young dies
in the movie
and luke doesn't knock over but he's
looking pretty cool but unfortunately
for here it looks like this is where
i'll have to end it for me guys they're
going to keep releasing character posts
oh damn really what else came out so
we're still left with the luke kang
poster i was hoping to see a jax poster
i wonder if they're gonna do a costume
reveal for scorpion because i feel like
that's something
they're gonna be saving for the actual
movie but nonetheless
be on the lookout for those character
posters if you guys like this video so
much i'll go ahead and make
sure i still thought it was good video
man part 2 what do you want to see out
of the trailer which so far has been
your favorite character poster
anything and everything be sure to leave
your thoughts down below don't forget to
like and subscribe
follow me on twitter at 3c film review
as always i'm chris
take care take care buddy let's see what
else came out if something did come out
since he uploaded this
okay so we're on the mortal kombat
twitter oh oh
we got our scorpion one right there damn
what a
beast not
shoulder plates that is not the scorpion
costume i am most accustomed to
we got to hear him if we can have joker
say at one point
we live in a society we gotta have him
at least one point say
get him get over here there is the jacks
poster right here
damn that's badass but not cato
no we only got too many robot parts in
this movie people are going to get
confused
and i love how the posters are motioned
like a video game avatar when you're
selecting these
yeah i think the arm detail here is just
much more made out as opposed to the
photos that we got before that looks
great anyone else here
damn i don't know man i still want my
chris lambert back we still got a white
watch writing
someone deep fake chris lambert into the
new movie
deep fake all the original cast he's got
a staff like out of the video game
badass i love it ass all right so that's
what we're caught up to date on so far
yeah that's that's where we're beating
chris
yeah yeah that's right chris you suck
that you suck
through the video
oh man but these posters do look awesome
i am super excited for this trailer
tomorrow we're going to be
do our absolute best to be as on top of
it we don't know the official time yet
for when it's coming out
we got multiple reports of the specific
time but do subscribe
hit that like button click that
notification bell
because this is a movie i'm very much
looking forward to
subscribe blah blah blah catch you guys
soon
you